good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation well I looked all
over for a bolo tie to wear tonight
because this is really a New Mexico
event this book Gwyneth Cravens grew up
there and rip Anderson has worked there
all his life they got to be friends and
they were on opposite sides of nuclear
issues and probably others as well and
whose mind got changed was not rips it
was Gwyneth and she has spent half a
decade working up a book which comes out
later this month you can order it now
from Amazon there's a cover out in the
table and lobby called power to save the
world and I have to be sent to me for a
blurb which I did and I did that and I
invited them to speak here because it's
such a damn good book basically it gets
away from a lot of the hand waving on
both sides that you see around there
clear and goes right into the the guts
of the matter and that's why I was
hoping that they could come and they
agreed to even before they go on the
roadshow for the for the book so please
welcome they've got some matter
[Applause]
hi I'm the writer and here's my Virgil
in the nuclear world D Richard Anderson
or rip as we call him first of all I
want to thank Stuart brand for inviting
us to speak after an article about him
appeared in the New York Times a retired
nuclear engineer wrote a letter to the
editor saying quote the nuclear industry
and the environmental movement need each
other in order to arrive at the common
goal of environmentally acceptable
energy generation on a large scale kudos
to Stuart brand for helping to bridge
the gap between the two unquote because
of Stuart we have now all seen the
picture of the whole earth there's not
really an environmentalist earth and a
nuclear power earth is just one planet
the poet Rumi said out beyond ideas of
wrongdoing and right doing there is a
field I'll meet you there
that's what my hope is and rips to we
hope that people in the environmental
media and members of the nuclear world
can come together to face the immense
challenge that is upon us we need to put
aside assumptions and look at facts as
Marie Curie said nothing in life is to
be feared it is only to be understood
now is the time to understand more so
that we fear less about ten years ago at
a party in Albuquerque my hometown I
fell into a conversation with rip about
nuclear power he and his wife Marcia
Fernandez who was over there
handling the slides Marsh is a community
activist and educator and they have an
organic sustainable farm near the Rio
Grande Rip's day job is as a scientist
but he has another job he's also a
beekeeper
and here he is in what looks like a
nuclear DK man 8 decontamination suit
but it's really a bee keepers outfit
rescuing a hive while thinking globally
ripp and Marsha work hard locally to
preserve clean air the aquifer and open
land they rescued a 10 acre former
airfield from the threat of development
and rounded up volunteers from the
community and sowed grain planted trees
and pretty soon they had a Wildlife
Sanctuary
those are cattle egrets not migrating
cranes actually if you want to learn
about rips youth as a cowboy in the
rodeo and on the range or his dive into
a reactor and how he became a
theoretical chemist an oceanographer and
an internationally known expert on risk
assessment and environmental health and
nuclear safety you'll just have to read
the book but back to that conversation
we had at the party he happened to
mention that a lot of our nuclear
warheads are now being dismantled and
their cores will be turned into fuel for
nuclear plants he said 10 percent of our
electricity already comes from former
Soviet warheads that surprised me and
the surprise just was beginning I didn't
know that then until that evening most
of what I knew about nuclear energy had
come from organizations that opposed
nuclear power
I had marched to ban the bomb in
Greenwich Village and by the way would
March again today in a minute to ban the
bomb and later on I protested the
opening of Shoreham a nuclear plant on
Long Island I wouldn't do that again in
addition to writing literary fiction in
the occasional science article I've been
a contributor to various liberal and
left publications and a magazine editor
as well I'm an organic gardener too and
a member of a sustainable organic
community farm in eastern Long Island
when ripp spoke favorably about nuclear
power that night I was annoyed and I
think those of you in the audience who
are in the nuclear world are probably
familiar with that irritated tone that
someone will take in a social event at
you but the dialogue continued each time
I saw him because he kept referring to
the long term to the big picture to what
the overall risks and benefits are I saw
that he thought on a big scale and in
terms of thousands of years he also
spoke about catastrophic climate change
he said we're heating up the planet
because of the sources of energy we
choose people get trapped by short-term
thinking and narrow focus he emphasized
the importance of objective
science-based
peer-reviewed information whether the
topic is global warming or nuclear power
he told me that the same probabilistic
risk assessment that gives us a portrait
of what we can expect from rising
temperatures is also used to analyze
nuclear safety yes but was usually my
response I brought up various nuclear
disaster scenarios he provided many
explanations and invoked laws of physics
finally he said why don't we visit the
nuclear world and you can see for
yourself so he and Marcia and I went on
the nuclear America tour it took a lot
of inquiry and fact-checking to change
my mind we'll give you some of the
highlights as we go along some of you
will be thinking yes but as Stewart said
there'll be a Q&A after the talk so you
can tell us your yes buds then or no but
no and because of rips fear about the
long-term impacts from burning fossil
fuels and now mine tonight we want to
talk about how nuclear power can be a
major part of the solution in the coming
decades and since
we'll talk about the overall picture of
the resources we have to make
electricity the increasing need for it
and the risks and benefits of different
forms of energy generation now and in
the future we're lucky in this society
to have a lot of choices but rip when it
comes to electricity production how many
options do we really have when we only
really have three options for baseload
electrical energy
they are hydro fossil fuels and nuclear
I need to stop for just a second and
explain what I mean by base load base
load is the capacity of the electrical
industry to instantaneously supply you
army with 24/7 electricity on-demand and
that means that you have to have an
instantaneous way of generating
additional electricity when the demand
goes up turns out that solar and
geothermal and a wind cannot do that you
don't
it only can be done by hydro by fossil
fuels and by nuclear okay so that
narrows it down tonight so we're talking
about nuclear power to something to a
great extent anyway when nuclear plants
are shut down they're replaced by fossil
fuel plants not wind or solar or
conservation for example Germany decided
to phase out nuclear power and they've
started plans to build 26 new
conventional coal-fired plants if they
hew to this plan and phase out nuclear
and build more coal plants despite the
impressive wind and solar installations
in the country greenhouse gas emissions
will rise there but it sounds like
they're backing off on the nuclear plant
shut down
okay this is projected energy use in
coming years there's been increased
inefficiency and better conservation
methods that have been coming along very
nicely especially in the industrial
sector for 20 or 30 years but the
private sector has lagged behind in
terms of conservation and efficiency the
digital revolution and fancy new
electronics and appliances and bigger
homes suck up a lot of electricity then
there are the developing nations that
really desperately need more electricity
in places without it the average
lifespan is 43 years bringing even a few
watts to a village increases survival at
the present rate electricity will
probably double by electricity demand
will probably double by 2030 as you can
see from the 2030 slaughter over there
we must be vigilant about wastefulness
but conservation alone is just a finite
resource we have to actually provide
more power and so we're on the cusp of a
big choice here as a society if we
continue the way we have fossil fuels
are going to be providing most of that
new electricity if you look at the
amount of electricity that's generated
in the United States you will see that
coal generates about 39 gas 19:07 hydro
16 nuclear 17 and all of the others are
about 2 percent if you look at this
circle you will notice that in essence
all except the hydro are the the energy
is generated by burning something could
I have the next slide I don't want to
make this look silly but really what
every one of those
do is boil lighter the water turns a
turbine the turbine swings magnets
through a field and generates the power
that you and I want to use so in essence
everything is boiling water I can get
the paper work here
could I have the next time from this
figure you will see that that there is
different amounts of material generating
different kilowatt hours of electricity
the real point here is that 7 grams
approximately the size of a pencil
eraser of uranium oxide will generate a
lot of energy comparing one kilogram of
oil for four kilowatt hours and one
kilowatt kilogram of uranium for 50,000
kilowatt hours of energy the next slide
this is a detailed slide the real thing
that I want to do for you to pick from
this slide is that uranium pellets and
the nuclear fuel cycle is a very very
concentrated energy source way more
concentrated than any other source that
we have available to us let's talk a
little bit about greenhouse gasses from
worldwide electricity production you can
see here the red indicates direct
emissions from power sources the white
the indirect emissions from the life the
comprehensive life cycle which includes
mining and waste disposal and all of
that so you can see that coal goes way
up that's the big killer and on the
other end
nuclear you can barely see it's ranges
between 21 and 9 grams of carbon dioxide
for
or co2 equivalent per kilowatt-hour so
nuclear power actually is has lower
emissions in terms of greenhouse gases
than wind it's certainly lower than
solar okay to give you an idea about the
volume of waste from coal as compared to
nuclear waste this is a picture of the
beautiful Sandia Mountains above
Albuquerque and they're about a mile and
a quarter high above the city
fossil fuel combustion produces 27
billion tons of carbon dioxide yearly
and in the world if if it was solidified
it would make a mountain the size of the
Sandia's there with a base of over 6
miles in circumference
the same quantity of energy provided by
nuclear fuel would produce only 14,000
tons of solid waste it would occupy a
cube that was about 18 yards on the side
about the volume of a big town house the
waste is always shielded and isolated
from the public and of course as we saw
there's no the gaseous waste is
negligible with nuclear okay if you got
all of your energy all of your
electricity for your entire life about
77 years is the average lifespan in
America then your share of the waste
would fit in one coke can if you got all
of your electricity just from coal
instead of the 51% on average we're
getting in this country over your life
you would be responsible for 69 tons of
solid waste and 77 tons of co2 and you
can see that it would take the all those
railroad cars to haul your waste around
so can we go back one a slide
Thanks
so there's the story the coal waste
statistics are so staggering that when
you begin to learn about them you don't
know why people aren't out marching
about this and picketing and demanding
coal plants be shut down and of course
we can't because we're totally addicted
to them we're dependent on that baseload
electricity but the solid waste from
coal combustion contains arsenic mercury
LEDs and other toxins
don't forget uranium I was gonna get to
that it's also it also contains uranium
thorium radium and we'll be talking
about that a little more later
and so our share of the waste at present
is 890 pounds per year for American the
total amount of waste from coal
combustion would take a million railroad
cars to haul it and that the Train made
of those railroad cars would be 9600
miles long over three times the distance
between New York and LA what we also
don't see about coal combustion that's
what it's doing to public health it's
not high drama for you know you don't
see a TV made-for-tv scary movie about
coal combustion but it's scary and oh by
the way this is a coal train if you've
made in case you've never seen one or
had to wait at a railroad crossing out
west for an hour while it goes by so the
next thing is the health impacts of coal
which are quite worrisome you can see
that around 24,000 people die a year
from power plant pollution in the United
States and that's chiefly coal you know
there's some natural gas and some oil
but really they're talking about coal
in China over 400,000 deaths a year from
coal pollution which you're now
receiving here in California
co-op Ellucian Richard Rhodes author of
making of the atomic bomb has written
the World Health Organization has
estimated that indoor and outdoor air
pollution from fossil fuel burning
causes some three million deaths per
year worldwide substituting small
sequestered volumes of nuclear waste for
vast dispersed volumes of toxic wastes
from fossil fuels would be an
improvement in public health so obvious
that it is astonishing that physicians
throughout the world have not demanded
such a conversion global warming it's to
me one of the biggest challenges that
man has ever faced in the first it's the
first time man has been has the
capability of doing something that can
impact the total earth in 1960 when I
was studying oceanography I was really
concerned about it but at that point in
time it was only a theory now I'm
convinced that global warming is real
and what we're really arguing about is
how hard or how high the temperature
that global warming will will occur over
the next while in addition I'm very very
worried about the negative effects of
Earth of that in addition to the
temperature increase I'm worried about
the fact that carbon dioxide when it
dissolves in the ocean generates
carbonic acid and carbonic acid
dissolves any carbonate shells of any
species in the ocean so it will
eliminate many of the critters that we
eat and enjoy watching like coral
oysters and
clams but even more importantly when the
when the ocean which is now basic but
changing slightly in pH values in an in
acidity when it becomes acid it will no
longer act as the mat the huge sponge
for sucking up co2 that it is now and it
won't suck up anymore to co2 therefore
the thermal global warming will be
accelerated and it I think we're heading
for a very very large problem both in
acidification in the ocean and in just
increasing the temperature of our globe
those greenhouse gases are mitigated
into a huge extent by nuclear power
which accounts for 71% of greenhouse gas
free electricity in the United States
it's the single largest displacer of
greenhouse gases in the world and is
likely to be so for a long time to come
it can and must replace fossil fuel as
baseload of course will lead all the
things week all the other solutions we
can get like solar you know whatever
solar power can do and wind power
geothermal tidal these are all part of
the deal but the heavy lifting is going
to have to be done the greenhouse gas
free heavy lifting will have to be done
by a nuclear if we're going to try to
save ourselves from the scenario rip is
talking about we're about to get to the
nuclear America tour but first let's
talk a bit about radiation exposure I
needed to know about that before I was
willing to go to nuclear facilities like
I tended not to distinguish high
radiation high dose radiation of the
kind that people suffered from in
Hiroshima and Nagasaki
I firefighters and emergency workers at
Chernobyl
I didn't distinguish that from the
low-dose radiation that we get and we
even emit in everyday life there's a lot
of ignorance about low-dose radiation
and fears that are completely
unwarranted we evolved in an ocean of
radiation that was actually much more
intense than it is today the ocean of
natural radiation is a deeper in some
places than others salt beds for example
have extremely low natural radioactivity
and then there are parts of the world
like part part of Iran where there's a
lot of radium in the soil and the water
and it's very highly radioactive and
parts of Brazil and India and China
where people live quite healthy lives by
the way most of our exposure human
exposure from natural background is from
radon that comes out of rocks like
uranium and thorium and also the sea
seawater is actually high in uranium
content which washes off the continents
and into the ocean and then there's
cosmic radiation from you know the solar
system in the universe which is greater
at higher altitudes to understand the
reference here a millirem is a measure
of the biological damage to living
tissue from radiation exposure below
10,000 millirem there is no scientific
basis for confirming whether damage
occurs or not it's just very hard to
know the effects of low-dose radiation
because of all the noise as it were of
natural background radiation so right
now a lot of our regulations about
radiation have to do with estimates the
science is really not there recent
research on load
radiation has found that it can
stimulate DNA repair mechanism so this
shows how we evolve you know that that
radiation actually played a role in our
way our DNA developed and helps our
immune system and this is a very
tantalizing subject and a controversial
one and obviously deserves more research
the panel on the biological effects of
ionizing radiation has called for more
low-dose research that panel establishes
or uphold standards and advises Congress
and so on how to promulgate the right
level of radiation standards there's a
campaign among radiation biologists
around the world to establish an ultra
low dose laboratory to get really solid
facts from carefully controlled studies
in a very low background radiation
setting half a mile under the ground in
a salt bed and we're going to talk more
about that very interesting salt bed
later then we have all sources of
radiation this graphic which I like so
much is actually now out of date the
National Committee on radiation
protection announced in July that
medical radiation the average dose for
American is about the same as natural
background radiation three hundred three
hundred milligram a year average for
medical radiations and on average 300
milligram a year for natural background
so you can see that there are different
types of radiation and I just want to
talk a little about where they come from
food for example is one way we take in
radiation from nature by eating isotopes
there are isotopes in foods and
therefore we emit low-dose radiation
because of radioisotopes in the food we
eat so here's some and the thing to know
about this chart this graphic is that
radiation has different penetrating
powers so you can hold a piece of
plutonium in your hand on a piece of
paper as rip has done and the rays
coming out of plutonium don't even
penetrate the paper and the skin stops
them too but others like beta and gamma
are more penetrating in neutrons but you
can see that they're all stopped by
concrete and concrete plays a very big
role in the nuclear world as you're
going to hear so I just wanted to show
you some things in daily life that are
radioactive for starters a salt
substitute which in radiation protection
classes they now use instead of a
radioactive source like americium or
plutonium or something
no salt will set off a Geiger counter
Brazil nuts the ones that are from
Brazil are grown in the thorium soils
and they radiation biologists I know
uses Brazil nuts to calibrate his Geiger
counter and cigarettes
if you smoke two packs a day of
cigarettes then in one year you have a
dose to your lungs of 8,000 to 20,000
millirem so every person in the nuclear
world that I and I interviewed a lot of
people and I would say well how how can
a person avoid excess radiation and I
thought they might say well shut down
nuclear plants or something like that
they said to a man and woman don't smoke
and then this beautiful orange plate is
Fiestaware
which will also set off a Geiger counter
we couldn't find a Geiger counter that
clicked rip has one but it doesn't click
and so it's no fun but this is a
radioactive and then bananas 0.01
millirem for every time you eat a banana
and a nuclear power plant if you live
next to it for a year they estimate
because it's so tiny they can't really
tell that your exposure is 0.009
millirem in a year so some people in the
nuclear world like to rate things in
banana years so something to think about
if you like bananas as much as I do is
you're really you know sucking up the
radiation okay
so I stopped worrying about excess
radiation exposure but then one day we
were rip and I were talking and he was
talking about reactors and I said you
know they're really unnatural this is
not something humans should be it's
something humans have brought into the
world we didn't have this before now we
have this terrible thing to deal with
reactors he replied that there were
reactors in nature
mother nature's reactors and I could not
believe that I thought as in the early
days with rip every now and then I would
thought he is he pulling my leg or is he
a little nuts or something like that so
I would always look up everything he
told me well I looked up natural
reactors and I found out about the Oklo
natural reactors in Gabon West Africa
starting around two billion years ago in
a river delta and called the Oklo 16
reactors natural reactors produced power
at about the hundred kilowatt level for
about 150 million years well rip what
was your secret to be honest with you I
did everyone's know I'll pull her leg
just to see if she was paying
and almost always she was the gabbana
reactor is a very interesting one in
fact there are 12 of them now that they
have found throughout the United States
and I'm sure as they look in other
geologic formations they will find
others in many geologic formations which
contain uranium the conditions were just
right to allow the chain reaction that
occurs in a reactor to occur there was
sufficient amount of uranium of the
right kind of course there was water to
carry away the heat and they ran for a
long period of time and what happened at
the end of that time they ran out of
fuel and they stopped that the unstable
atoms that were being burned were
finally gone and they left the
radionuclides some of them and some
stable atoms there which was the key to
the French experimentalist that found
the first one that said one it was a
reactor two it ran for a long period of
time and three most of the fission
fragments the radionuclides never moved
out of the geologic formation which was
the first natural proof that that
geologic formations really do contain
radioactivity
well when we talk about the gabon
reactor we have to start back and say
what is the chain reaction and that you
know what is radioactive decay first I
jumped over a slide radioactive decay is
in effect an unstable atom breaking
apart in some way giving off particles
radiation and a lot of heat of course
and that heat then it can be used if you
can figure out how to trap it and the
next slide then is what is a nuclear
chain reaction a nuclear chain reaction
is when a neutron from one unstable atom
flies out and hits another unstable atom
and breaks it apart and that chain
continues until all of the unstable
atoms have been used up or enough
neutrons escaped without hitting an
unstable atom that the chain reaction
stops next slide how does a reactor work
well brought by now with that crazy
cartoon up front you probably know it
the unstable atoms break apart being hit
by neutrons and causing others to break
apart and that energy boils water and
the water is cycled through the
appropriate tool to generate electricity
and and electricity goes out on the
wires well I just want to talk a little
bit on the nuclear tour we started out
at the looking at the cradle of uranium
in the United States it really starts
out in the Sun or in rather in a
supernova supernova why make uranium
atoms but we went to ambrosia Lake in
New Mexico and
looked at what sort of the remains of a
completely moribund uranium mining
industry it used to during the Cold War
and early development of nuclear power
was a very busy place the Colorado
Plateau is very rich in uranium that
volcanic action brought up from the core
of the Earth's you know mantle and a
typical I'm sure a lot of you would be
familiar with the landscape of the
Colorado Plateau which is rugged and
beautiful and contains things like the
Grand Canyon next slide please
that's the Colorado Plateau and that's
you know the kind of place that they
would bring uranium out of but they're
not doing it there you're any mining in
the US has virtually shut down I heard
there were about a hundred and twenty
one uranium miners actually doing mining
and it's a kind of thing called insight
to leaching where they just take water
out of old mines and take their uranium
out of that water okay so and there's
some different types of uranium this is
a uranium refinery that we visited that
was the biggest refinery yellowcake in
the maker you know producer of
yellowcake in the free world in its
heyday and it was being dismantled when
we visited and now if you go there
there's no trace of it it's been
completely torn down and the soil has
been planted and the tailings piles
which were once huge have been kind of
graded and smoothed out and capped and
stabilized so they you know new
refineries will have to be built if
mining resumes so the ore was trucked
from here and by the way one truckload
of uranium ore contains this equivalent
of energy of 1 million pound of tons of
coal
it was taken to the or was taken to a
plant where the yellow I'm not the or
the yellow cake was taken to a plant
where it was turned into gas through
chemical processes and then that gas was
sent to an enrichment plant to create to
produce more to isolate out more
uranium-235 from the other isotopes
uranium for nuclear fuel has been
enriched to four percent so one of those
pellets like you saw in the earlier
picture has 4% u-235 which is the
fissile isotope to enrich for a bomb you
would need to enrich at 90% which is why
you can never have a nuclear plant
explode atomically no matter how hard
you try to make that happen I can't it's
not possible so this is a the pellets go
into fuel rods and you can get an idea
of the size of a fuel rod from the hand
there and the fuel rods then are put
into a fuel assembly which they're just
bundled together and then that fuel
assembly winds up in reactor core this
is a research reactor core and here's a
plug for research reactors they're
responsible for making medical isotopes
among other things and those isotopes
and diagnostic and therapeutic
radiations save millions of lives
annually did you want to say something
about the no I was just showing the top
of a fuel bundle you saw an earlier one
and then this is where it sets in in the
reactor itself then we have a plant
reactor core and it's hard to tell from
the picture what how big that is but
it's surprisingly small a reactor core
is about twelve feet in diameter and
twelve feet tall so it could fit you
and kitchen in Menlo Park or Palo Alto
Gwen just one other side each one of
these little squares is the top of one
of those fuel bundles that you saw
earlier and then this is Oconee nuclear
station in South Carolina we visited
it's in a very wooded surrounded by
woods and big lake and Dam that's the
Duke Energy made the cylinders you see
in the back there are the where the
reactors are and the containment
buildings and we'll get to that in a
minute in the foreground is the turbine
building which is a gigantic building
with a floor so clean you really could
eat off of it as they were proud of
pointing out okay okay
oh Coney is a phenomenal plant but it's
just a typical one so the amount of
electricity generated in a day a week or
a year is measured in kilowatt hours or
megawatt hours Oconee recently became
the first Nuclear Station in the country
to generate 500 million megawatt hours
of electricity enough power to supply
electricity for 20 years to every house
in South Carolina that's two million
households and the Oconee did all this
taking up less than a square mile so
keep that in mind the environmental
footprint of a nuclear plant is really
small compared to the power it puts out
so okay that the white cylinders I
pointed out to you in the photographer
the photograph of the Oconee plant
here's what they look like inside which
we've already seen this that's here's
the inside and note that the reactor
core is below ground
and how about the spent fuel from
Bocconi first of all it's we know we
produced all that energy was emitting
virtually no greenhouse gases all the
spent fuel generated by one of oak oneis
reactors in a single year about 25 tons
could fit in the bed of ripps pickup
truck the annual total of spent fuel
from all of our 104 power reactors comes
to about 2,000 tons and how does this
compare to coal combustion uranium
yields pound-for-pound the greatest
amount of energy of any fuel we have
yeah but what about safety a nuclear
plant as I said can never explode
atomically and I didn't know that for
quite a while and so rip and I would
have conversations and I kept thinking
yeah but you know one of those things
could blow but you know they can't this
is we've visited Argonne West which is
now merged with Idaho National
Laboratory anyway it's all called Idaho
National Laboratory but at that time
it's called Argonne where a lot of
pioneering of reactors was done in the
50s 60s they took reactors past their
limits to find out just what it took to
create meltdowns and they figured out
the fuel configuration and all kinds of
important things about that that are
used worldwide now came from places labs
like this one note the containment
building it's a pressurized dome to so
that if anything happened if there
wasn't some kind of release of radiation
inside the building radioactive material
it would the air would go flow into the
dome not out and notice also that the
turbine building is separate from the
reactor there was a an uproar of a minor
kind about
of problem with a turbine and at a
reactor in Vermont the power plant
Vermont as if this was a terrible thing
that was just proof that nuclear power
didn't work but turbines are in a
separate building they don't have
anything really to do with the nuclear
part they just turn you know the steam
just turns the turbines so back to the
pressurized water reactor diagram again
note the size of the containment
relative to the reactor core and as I
said the core is underground the reactor
the reactor buildings at Oconee are each
19 stories high but 12 of those stories
are underground the reactors are
anchored at the bottom in bedrock a
hundred feet below the surface to
provide natural shielding the core is
enclosed by large carbon steel vessel
with a thick steel liner and walls of
dense concrete about five inches thick
and remember concrete stops radiation
this concrete vessel in turn sits within
the containment building which is made
of a shell of steel covered with four to
six feet of concrete reinforced with
steel bars and negatively pressurized as
I said before they can contain any
explosion or leak and in the case of
Three Mile Island definitely did anyone
entering has to pass through an airlock
this of course we did not get in a
containment building at Oconee or the
other nuclear plant we visited on our
tour this is in at Argonne at this
former reactor you know where a reactor
was formerly test and so on it's been
cleaned up and so we could walk into the
building go through the airlock take
pictures of the airlock door and all of
that with no concern about radioactivity
and you can see how just how thick that
door is
there have been two partial core
meltdowns in the history of commercial
or civilian nuclear power the
containment at Three Mile Island
prevented the escape of radioactive
material and no one was hurt
I I couldn't believe it when I heard
when rip told me that the death toll
from Chernobyl was very small and an
actually in one month in the United
States coal kills more people by far
than were killed in the Chernobyl
incident there been a 60 deaths that can
be directly attributed to Chernobyl most
of them were the emergency workers that
firefighters and nine have been
unfortunately children who got thyroid
cancer that wasn't treated and that was
completely they if they had been given
potassium iodide pills
there would have been no problem with
thyroid cancer in Poland and other areas
that were exposed to radiation from
Chernobyl where people were given
potassium iodide there was no problem it
potassium iodide blocks the uptake to
the thyroid of radioactive iodine all US
nuclear plants have to have containment
chernobyl had no containment that is why
Chernobyl is such a bad thing that
happened it was completely unnecessary
if it had containment it would have been
another Three Mile Island there are
details about the design and everything
but that's basically the bottom line on
Chernobyl all US nuclear plants have to
have containment and they have to have
backup provisions for water keeping
water supply to the reactor and keep it
cool and backup electrical systems in
case of a power failure or something
okay the other thing you see at a
nuclear plant or don't see in our case
they didn't want us to see that was the
subterranean spent fuel pool it's by the
way it's for security reasons that they
didn't want us to we did get to see a
Spence after a lot of security clearance
and all of that stuff we got to see a
spent fuel pool at the Idaho National
Lab and to see people working with spent
fuel there and walk along the pool and
perfectly safely by the way there these
pools are subterranean so again they
would present a very difficult target
for any terrorists who wanted to try to
crash a plane into what is in effect a
swimming pool and people worried what if
terrorists told spent nuclear fuel well
they would just die immediately because
it's so radioactive if they had a and
they need to get big cranes to load it
on to a van with with specially
reinforced axles and then they need to
get it out of the nuclear plant without
anyone noticing
and they're very well guarded plants and
I just don't think you you know a
terrorist with the brain would try that
then you have again people worry about
planes flying it in nuclear plants just
looking at this graphic will tell you
why it wouldn't work very well rip told
me rip was in charge during 9/11 you
were in charge of one of your jobs
counterterrorism at Sandia National Labs
and so I was calling him every two
minutes about disaster scenarios and he
said the World Trade Center and the
Pentagon are as made of paper in
comparison to what a nuclear plant is
made of so the plane would just pancake
against that structure like that and did
in fact had a test at Sandia ok so
nuclear plants are very safety-conscious
we were nagged
like you know with a oh by
overprotective grandma type people the
whole time we were there and we had to
wear a special protective gear and we
had to be wanded and we had to be we had
to fasten our seatbelts if we drove from
one of the turbine building to the
reactor building or whatever they are
very very safety conscious and in fact
they have an extremely low accident rate
and I believe it was OSHA discovered
that you're actually at greater risk for
an accident working in real estate than
in nuclear plants so this is a gamma-ray
counter at the at Argonne West we have
been in a fuel processing facility
reprocessing and when you enter an exit
these plants you're always checked for
excess radiation which is another reason
terrorists couldn't disguise himself as
a nuclear tourist and just put some
radioactive material in his pocket and
slip out and do damage with it couldn't
happen so I was quite satisfied by this
point that nuclear plants were operated
safely we also visited coal-fired plant
which was you know meeting the standards
that coal-fired plants are expected to
meet especially given that the
regulations tend to be written by the
coal industry and it's the only time I
saw rip looking nervous in the whole
nuclear tour because of leaky pipes and
stuff that would never be permitted and
nuclear facility okay so and just to
make sure that I didn't pick up any
radiation on that part of the tour after
it ended I had a whole body scan with
National Institutes of Health
state-of-the-art of gamma ray detector
whole body no excess radiation found all
right very well but what about the waste
from making electricity I asked that
question a lot and since ripped is an
expert on nuclear waste disposal I
learned a lot from him about it everyone
always asks about the waste I now say
when people bring up the state the
nuclear waste is just it's a staggering
quantity and we don't know what to do
with it I now say yeah but what about
fossil fuel waste and it's lethal
components this is a slurry dam at a
coal processing operation where they cut
off the top of a mountain in Appalachia
and those flurry dams sometimes break
and the toxic waste gets into the water
supply in a big way that happened in
Kentucky this is the beautiful Four
Corners area and these are huge
coal-fired plants that you can see the
plume I've flown over sometimes the
plume goes from just tens hundreds of
miles it's a huge operation and you
begin to realize the fossil fuel waste
is not stored in a it's not sequestered
and stored in an underground repository
it's stored in our tissues in the air in
the water in soil and by the way it
produces low-dose radiation if you're
concerned about radiation you should be
fighting coal plants because you get
more exposure from a coal-fired plant
the four-corners plants would expose you
to four millirem a year and remember
nuclear plant 0.009 millirem a year you
can be pretty sure none of us will ever
encounter spent nuclear fuel in
lifetimes it took some doing for us to
even get a glimpse of it at the Idaho
National Laboratory as for the quantity
of spent nuclear fuel that's how much
has been produced in 50 years of
commercial power 77 thousand tons that's
about one tenth of what one big
coal-fired plant can produce in one day
those 77 thousand tons could all fit in
a big Target or Best Buy store with room
left over now most of the people you
know when I would come back from these
nuclear excursions tell about things
we're surprised to learn that the United
States already has a successfully
operating deep geologic nuclear waste
repository it only stores defense waste
at this point but tests show it could
store spent nuclear fuel to rip led the
risk assessment team that got this site
the Waste Isolation Pilot Plant or whip
certified by the Environmental
Protection Agency so rip can nuclear
waste be safely stored it sure can the
what program was a wonderful program and
it's been operating for some quite some
time I know we're running a little bit
long so what I'm going to do is just
quickly pop through a bunch of slides
that shows you some of the operations
that are occurring at WIPP right now and
then during the question and answer if
there are other information that you
would like we can come back to it
because I do enjoy talking about what I
can talk to you all night about it okay
next slide this is well you and passed
away that's a true pact being carrying
nuclear waste from somewhere like Idaho
to Carlsbad which is southeastern New
Mexico the three barrels which you saw
in there and here they are again each
contain 14 barrels 55-gallon drums of
waste and this guy is swabbing the
barrels to check and see if there's any
Tama nation before it's taken into the
website this is the waste that is in
those barrels and you can see it's a
mock-up of course there's lab coats
there's paper towels
there's lab where there's resins there's
junk that's what's being put there next
slide I won't go through this slide at
all but it was opened in 1999 and there
has been no accidents to date and New
Mexicans are at peace with it and the
local people in Carlsbad New Mexico
they're near a city love where they love
it okay this is the design in pictorial
form at the place where you saw the
truck being scanned for radioactivity
this is the receiving dock there are
four shafts that go down from the
surface a half a mile and the shelves
penetrate rock for about a thousand feet
and then the rest of the time it's
bedded salt the haulage ways here are
for taking waste to the repository rooms
these are the rooms each room is is
about a hundred meters long and 30
meters wide this is the quarter that's
cutting the salt to make the the rooms
and you can see the teeth there you can
see where it's chewed up the room salt
mines very easily next slide the drums
that are being put in in the whip room
right now and you can see that they've
got some support members in the in the
ceiling just because salt is like silly
putty and it tends to creep that's why
salts a good place to put the waste in a
few tins to a hundred years the salt
will creep in both from the ceiling the
floor on the sides and in come in in
case all of this waste in a salt cocoon
and then finally when the when the
repository is full the shafts are sealed
there will be some kind of a marker
system we had
marker study - to try to tell future
societies that there was danger in the
ground and don't drill here or don't dig
here and this is one of the pictures
they have nuclear plants are moving
spent fuel from pools after the fuel
cools down to interim storage in
air-cooled dry casks of thick concrete
the nuclear industry pays one tenth of a
cent per kilowatt hour which goes into a
waste repository fund no US taxpayer
dollars are collected to pay for
commercial nuclear waste this fund is
financing the study to determine the
feasibility of a central repository in
Nevada at the Nevada Test Site and this
is on top of Yucca Mountain looking
toward a place where a lot of bomb
craters are from atomic explosions over
900 have taken place I've been about a
test site
it's a 5,000 mile a square mile
reservation surrounded by other federal
land the decision to put a waste
repository at Yucca Mountain was mainly
a political one the land was federally
owned a tunnel has been board five miles
into the granite tuff of the mountain
and studies are being conducted there
rip has been participating in an
internal peer review of the science of
Yucca Mountain project and this is a
schematic this is just it's everything
is at the conceptual stage with Yucca
Mountain in terms of how exactly the
waste is going to be put in there
they're looking at all kinds of
possibilities this is one system that's
a possible way they'll do it as I said
earlier whip was wanted by the people in
Carlsbad and has been accepted by the
people of New Mexico even the
anti-nuclear guys in New Mexico
grudgingly admit that whip is safer than
they thought it was going to be
but the state of Nevada does not want it
repository so there are ongoing court
battles every single person I talked to
about Yucca Mountain who's associated
with the project said the problems are
political not technical
okay this is it in May 2007 the
International Panel of the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change is draft report stated that only
a concerted action requiring a huge
monetary investment and a profound
change in policy can avert a climate
collapse and that intervention must be
accomplished by 2020 the IPCC
recommended a variety of interventions
of all kinds hybrid cars carbon capture
nuclear power and the UN expects a large
increase in human fatalities especially
in poor countries as micro climates
disappear and whole ecological systems
give way will the civilization that has
been elaborated for hundreds of
generations withstand the greatest
challenge it has ever faced ultimately
the whole nuclear tore it led me to that
question it's clear that the benefits of
nuclear power far outweigh the risks and
these I'm gonna if you'll bear with me
I'm gonna read them aloud because this
is really these are all the things that
changed my mind about nuclear power and
led me to be sitting up here today
telling you why I think it's so
important that we really take a good
look at nuclear power uranium is very
energy dense a small quantity equals a
huge amount of power they're huge
reserves of uranium in geopolitically
favourable spots fuel can be recycled
many times only 2% is used if the fuel
is it just takes one trip to the reactor
mature it's a mature technology the new
reactor designs there many and
prototypes show that you can have a
reactor that consumes its own waste you
can produce hydrogen on a large scale
there's a project going on in Idaho
right now with a reactor like that u.s.
reactors operated over ninety five
percent capacity no
their system of energy generation can
claim that kind of capacity over 12,000
reactor years have been passed and
safety as I said nuclear plant has a
very small environmental footprint and
nuclear plant radiations are radiation
emissions are less than you get from
eating a banana a year the lowest
environmental impact of any large-scale
energy source and as I said before the
biggest displacer of greenhouse gases on
the planet Harvard MIT study suggests
that a tripling of the world's 440
reactors would result in a 25% reduction
in greenhouse gases rip one day told me
a story about a man who was warned about
a flood rip would you tell the story yes
this is kind of an old joke but I hope
you'll bear with me there was a man that
got caught up in a flood and the police
came by his house and said you better
evacuate and he said God will save me
and then the water rose up a ways and
both come by and the boat said do you
want us to save you and he said no God
will save me the water got to the top of
the roof and the helicopter come by and
he they said you went me too you want us
to save you and he said no God will save
me well the man drowned and when he
arrived at st. Peter's the pearly gates
where Saint Peter was he said why didn't
you save me and see Peter said I sent a
policeman about in the helicopter you
are ignored them all well one day God
could very well say I gave you the
brainiest people ladies and men I gave
you an understanding of radioactive
decay I gave you enough uranium and
thorium to last year thousands of years
I gave you the knowledge and how to
harness the energy so it wouldn't harm
the environment
are you while you were using it what
else do you want well I think tonight we
have skimmed the top of many of the
arguments for nuclear energy if you want
to learn more about it
read the book
I just wanted to actually do on it know
more about it just I have one last line
of the punch line is the power to save
our world does not lie in rocks rivers
wind or sunshine it lies in each of us
well the question is really fall into
some the themes you might imagine
there's one from Kevin bile are you
Kevin right here in the long emergency
Howard Kunstler he's actually one of the
environmentalists whose hard over for
nuclear is your interesting it states
that the earth holds only 150 years
worth of nuclear fuel how this just play
into long-term plans particular energy
you see please comment on uranium mining
says Michael P and the reliability of
uranium is a fuel long in the future
I've heard predictions of peak uranium
production around 2030 to 2040 and Susan
says yeah but say dramatic need leads
for energy leads to huge demand and
growth and nuclear energy industry that
means mining uranium and far greater
quantities in the past what's the danger
of that what's the degradation of
geographical geological sites and is
uranium finite or how long will the
supply last so there and I've heard this
from a lot of times there sure you have
what's the uranium supply situation
you're going to take the first cut
Clinton well rip can talk to you about
how much uranium and thorium there is on
the earth and how we can we basically
have an indefinite supply because it can
be reprocessed they now you know they
mix one of the waste products of in
spent nuclear fuel is plutonium but it
can be burned as a fuel so the French
now when they reprocess fuel they mix
that plutonium back yea they blend it
down with depleted uranium and you know
create fuel so it's basically
you know recyclable was sustainable I
mean there are some people in new
nuclear world consider nuclear power
sustainable and they make a good case
for that
and if we just ran out of every last
atom of uranium on the planet we could
go to thorium which is even more
abundant than uranium and has some
benefits for example it's a very it's
more proliferation proof in terms of
mining so I don't think there's Peak
uranium I I don't believe that because
of when the we talked to the mining
former chairman of the mining Commission
in New Mexico and he was talking about
the huge reserves of good quality or
just in New Mexico that you know since
the the bottom dropped out of the
uranium market when we were there in
2002 I think it was uranium was $7 a
pound and this summer it was up to
something like 134 dollars a pound and
what Terri Fletcher said to us that and
when we talked to him in New Mexico was
just if the price is right there's
endless amounts of uranium to be mined
and they they haven't even they stopped
prospecting so there's probably uranium
that hasn't even been found so I just
don't think that's a problem and in
terms of mining the regulations today
for uranium mining are much different
from during the uranium booms and in
terms of miners safety once they
discovered that radon was causing lung
cancer rates to go up among miners they
started ventilating the mines so that
they're like wind tunnels now or they I
mean they they're no actually they
became like wind tunnels I need to use
the past chance because I I don't
believe it as much if any hardrock
uranium mining going on right now but
and again smokers
got higher rates of lung cancer because
of the interaction there's a synergy of
some kind between radon and the
radioisotopes in cigarette smoke
so miners would be at no greater risk
today from mining uranium then they
write mining is a risky business but
just ask a coal miner about that also a
miner uranium miner takes out in one day
the same amount of energy containing or
as a coal miner takes out in a month so
the quantity of coal that has to be
mined to light these light bulbs in this
beautiful room is so far greater than
the quantity of uranium that has to be
mined that there's just no comparison
I've got a question reprocessing
relating of that which is sort of that
both ends of the you know right now
we're mining Soviet nuclear weapons and
they're not yet but we'll move on to
mining u.s. nuclear weapons and we're
sticking to my so there's a lot of a
plutonium there to degrade down to fuel
you've been dealing now with the Yucca
Mountain and so you're looking at the
quantities of waste mostly in these dry
cask storage some of them still on the
pool switch is it true you swam in one
of those pools well not really it was
worse than that way back when when I was
bulletproof and ten feet tall one of the
research reactors at Sandia Labs which
was a flash reactor they couldn't get
some of the bolts at the top of the spin
of the fuel bundles loose and two of us
negotiated and dived down into the
reactor and unbold at the bolts because
it was quicker and easier and we had
Geiger counters and such in there so
that we knew that we weren't getting any
higher radiation and we
standing out on the on the edge of the
pool but it was rather interesting to do
rip is a certified diver don't try this
at home
bungee jumping
bungee jumping is not as safe one one
more thought on the first question if
you look how oil exploration has
occurred every time we get really short
and oil somebody comes up with a brand
new find on a major oil cache if and
when we get into the in the need for
uranium
we have only started to prospect for the
uranium we're gonna find it everywhere
and it is in the ocean waters - you can
get it out of the ocean water there's
lots and lots of it there well just in
terms of the stuff which is in the dry
cast storage and the the ones through
process that we do in the u.s. that I
guess almost nobody else in the world
does can we take that and reprocess it
if we resume reprocessing how much juice
is in that so-called spent fuel it's
very easy to do to take the spent fuel
and reprocess in fact the older the
spent fuel is the less radioactive it is
and therefore the the easier it is to
run it through the correct process or
whatever the produ process will be so
what would be the volume reduction of
say suppose we do as we're planning I'll
put all of the spent fuel on a once
threw into Yucca Mountain if we didn't
do that
since now that's in there yet but
reprocessed all of it and put the the
waste that's left over from reprocessing
and put it in the mountain what's the
difference in volume oh it's a huge
volume reduction because you if you put
in the spent fuel bundles you're putting
in mainly air volume or volume to begin
with and then in addition to that what
you're putting in if you put in the fuel
bundle is you're putting in all of the
zirconium rod
coatings so even if you didn't reprocess
but you just separated out the uranium
pellets it would be hard to do but if
you did you would be cutting down your
volume by over fifty sixty percent then
if you process and save the uranium and
the plutonium and only had the fission
fragments and solidified them in say a
glass log which is what people are
suggesting to do now even with the
increase of the volume you would need
for the glass to to keep it the
radionuclides that you don't want
dissolved in the glass you would
increase it maybe to twenty percent of
the volume you started with I mean the
sagebrush four billion Nevada we're very
familiar with Nevada now foundation
because we're talking about putting a
clock on one of their mountains that's
why I went to Yucca Mountain was not to
think about nuclei were to think about
holes and mountains in Nevada and Nevada
is the sagebrush pavilion is alive and
well in terms of them not wanting feds
putting nuclear waste in their mountain
so as opposed Harry Reid senator W know
ahead of the Senate now successful and
heading that off for a good long time
could we put the waste in your weapon
New Mexico actually changed some rules
yes we politically it would be quite
difficult technically when we were
studying whether it was safe to put
transuranic which is what was put in
what is being put in whip right now if
we wanted to put spent field we carried
out many spent fuel simulation studies
where we put containers that were the
size of a several fuel bundles into the
wall with with electric heaters and
heated them up for many many years and
soldering the response of the salt to
that heating and it turns out it was
very very good remembered the National
Academy way back when when they were
- to look at what to do with nuclear
waste or spent fuel the National Academy
said put it in salt because it has a
higher thermal conductivity gets rid of
the heat it has a capability of acting
like city putty
silly putty and in company in in
entombing understand the feeling sort of
the C's way down there ceilings come
down in fact part of the problem with
operating whip is the haulage ways which
have to be open while you fill up all
the rooms do the same thing the roofs
come in and the sights come in and so
they have to keep mining the walls and
ceilings to keep it open while they fill
up the individual rooms
well you're the technical guy if it was
not a political issue would you rather
put our nuclear energy waste and whipper
and Yucca Mountain the first thing I
would do was make sure that I saved the
98 percent of the energy that was in the
spent fuel so I'd reprocess it and then
you could put it in either place from
what I can tell from the review that I
have done on Yucca Mountain the mountain
is a good mountain and it will protect
mankind from the fission fragments for
as long as needed but it's a major
political problem what do you think of
the science that's going on there for
the last 30 years
there's been some very good science at
Yucca Mountain and there's been some
questionable science and there's been
some politics that have made the
scientists look bad when they were
really only grumping about I really
don't want to do this additional quality
assurance it's a boring mountain I have
to say yes it is Alexandros rightly
raises so much of what our discussion is
about the US and the US actually is the
largest national producer of nuclear
power in the world but still most of the
demand is coming as
in the world alexandros asks since most
of the new power generation is coming
from developing nations are we going to
give nuclear technology to them what
about Brazil Indonesia places like that
we're giving some to India now I
understand they're planning to expand by
tenfold this this is I'm sorry Richard
Rhodes isn't here tonight because this
is his beat but this is this is going to
have to be done in an intelligent way I
think and based on what I know and there
are our several prospects here one is to
have an international consortium that
controls the has been fuel and and
leased basically leases the fuel and
takes it back and reprocess is it so
that you don't have countries with their
own uranium enrichment plants you can't
make a nuclear weapon from nuclear power
plant but if you just have a uranium
enrichment plant you can enrich all the
uranium you want so I this this is
tricky another thing is that dick Rhodes
wrote a wonderful piece called the genie
is out of the bottle which is in fact
the case that sooner or later people can
figure out that once you know the secret
of radioactive decay producing energy
you can come up with the technology to
harness that and so it's I think you
know the idea of tripling the number of
reactors we're going to have more
reactors and we have to have all kinds
of international was Stuart was saying
earlier before the talk global
bureaucrats who go around and just
inspect and inspect inspect the way the
International Atomic Energy Agency does
to make sure people aren't pulling stuff
like they were in North Korea now
they've really sat on North Korea and
things seem to be calming down
there so I don't know if that answers
the question I think one of the speakers
we had in this series was Richard
rockefeller and they have to go to his
wedding a couple months ago in Maine and
he's been very much involved the
Rockefeller Brothers fund and their CEO
is it turns out a diplomat who engages
in all sorts of things one of them is
dealing with the Iran
everybody is major concern these days
besides North Korea in terms of
proliferation is what if you know is
Iran
what's Iran doing with all of this
nuclear energy they've got all that oil
they must be just building a bomb two
things one is they really need the
nuclear energy it turns out and in some
ways we would all people that if they
did is take some of the pressure off of
oil and less greenhouse gas and so on
but what about the bomb aspect and what
the Rockefeller Brothers fund is on the
brink of getting is an agreement for
exactly this kind of basically offshore
reprocessing with the fuel so they're
not doing reprocessing that Mike and
Richard all the way toward weapons-grade
it's being done outside they basically
rent the service and the sticking point
at this point in the negotiations is
will the plant that does that be inside
the borders of Iran or not and Iran says
well of course it will and some of the
other people are saying that's not a
sincere enough answer it needs to be
outside the borders of the RAM so that's
the the stage they're out with that one
I guess I'd like to approach your
question or the answer to your question
in a little bit different way I've
studied global warming and its effects
as I indicated earlier for many many
years and I think we're hitting at about
90 miles an hour for at a very very very
big brick wall and if we don't come up
with some other way to stop it or slow
it down we're going to be splattered all
over the wall and one way when you come
to developing nations they need energy
we can either force them to burn fossil
fuels or we can come up with some way
that we can give them the nuclear energy
that they're given the energy they need
through the nuclear process and protect
the proliferation and I think in the
long term we only have one answer to
that we've got to someway come up with
with giving them energy through the
nuclear option and then protecting for
proliferation by reprocessing somewhere
offshore or just bringing the fuel back
and processing it at in one of the
countries as France does now with Japan
well what's the you take climate change
very seriously I do and your sense of
urgency sounds strong one of the
critiques of nuclear energy is that
there's this huge lead time to get a
plant on I get it through the process
licensed funded bill finally online and
to do it at the scale you're talking
about to actually deal with the
massiveness of the problem we're talking
about is the timeframes match order that
we basically get you know sufficient
nukes to thinness to wait I think that
if we tomorrow started a major process
both in the United States and in the
developing countries of formalizing a
nuclear process meaning one kind of a
reactor where you could go when when you
train the people they could go to any
one reactor any of a number of reactors
and fix the reactor the same way rather
than every single reactor and this is an
over s overstatement but every single
reactor we have now the reactor
technicians have to go in and say oh now
this is a left-handed nut this is a
right hand in that this is not a nut
it's a clip and and so it may it mix the
the costliness of treating those
reactors very very very high and it
makes the safety less if each time you
have to go in and say geez I don't know
whether I want to turn this right here
left it means that you have added some
level of uncertainty on the safety of
that reactor so there's a lot of steps
that have to be done but if we don't
store
now we're going to be in real trouble
we're already seeing as an oceanographer
now the coastal areas changing pH by 1/2
a pH unit now why is it coastal because
the currents in the coast under the from
the shore to the continent edge of the
continental shelf that's where the water
is continuously stirred from dock bottom
to top and that's changing pH units as
we speak there's a question from Eric
Sachs be getting down to practicalities
Eric how does the industry for acquiring
nuclear nuclear fuel I almost did a
Bush's and their nuclear nuclear fuel
mining transport all this stuff compared
with fossil fuels with regard to
greenhouse gas emission and
environmental pollution others the
process all the stuff happens where you
get the from the ground to the or to the
refinery to the reactor is that using a
lot of fossil fuel no we thought Marsha
can you bring up that the greenhouse gas
emissions the comparative emissions
lifecycle while you search I'll ask
another question from Tom are there
sufficient experienced nuclear
scientists and engineers to support a
massive expansion and nuclear power no
so that's the limited resource not
uranium is engineers one of the more
critical resources is indeed nuclear
energy years that know how to run
reactors in this country and the world
were in in in the world but for sure in
the United States it takes I don't know
whether you've any of you have looked at
the training and a nuclear reactor
driver if you want to call him goes
through but it is horrendous they go
through psychological tests they go
through physical tests they go through
all kinds of tests
and and they they train in simulators
more than the pilots that you guys fly
in airplanes do I'll vouch for this by
the way I get invited to speak at
gatherings of nuclear industry people
because my message to them is you're all
environmentalists now here's how to act
green and they jump and they haven't
seen Al Gore's movie and all this kind
of stuff but when I looked at an
audience of these characters they're old
farts and busy retiring and when they
talked to me afterwards it's where are
we gonna get the young people I said you
know I'll help you get the young people
but one you gotta hire them to you got
to get them a lot of power early on and
three they're probably in if they come
they're now they're gonna be green and
they're gonna have a green agenda and
you just get used to that but whether
that's really going to happen I don't
know I hear that some of the engineering
schools there is either Schwartz nodding
his head that there are people going to
nuclear engineering now that it's hip
again and we'll see what happens but
again there's a lag time there is a lag
time but the longer we wait the worse
everybody wants to know this one is from
Michael of audio what's the worst case
force a plant meltdown spent nuclear
fuel being released in the environment
over thousands of years some of the
terrorist attack I mean that's a risk
guy you're always looking at what can go
wrong what can go wrong okay well he's a
risk guy but and so I'll I'll turn it
over to him but I just want to say we
did have the worst of the worst of the
worst happen in Chernobyl it was the
worst plant design it was the run by a
political hack and they decided to do an
experiment that involved cutting off the
water the coolant water to the reactor
core the channels and the graphite the
reactor was made of graphite and if it
gets hot enough graphite burns and the
channels sucked air as there was a fire
that sucked more air down and created
more of a fire the weather pattern that
day was very bad
the Soviets you know didn't want to
anyone to find out about this accident
so they were trying to cover it up so
they didn't want to evacuate people and
the plume there was no containment so
that we we know what the worst case
scenario looks like which is a
combination of terrible bureaucracy and
politics bad design and very poor safety
engineering the rip if you can talk
about the kind of risk assessment that
went into reactor design nuclear plant
design in the United States and why all
the reactors in the United States have
containment buildings
yeah the to add before I do that Dad
what Gwen said if we look at the two
accidents the Chernobyl accident and the
Three Mile Island accident both of those
resulted from someone who was less than
adequately trained turning off the water
and that's equivalent to saying to a
fireman who was trying to fight a
three-alarm fire hey turn off the water
fight the fire without water you can't
do it almost all of that kind of
activity now has been modified through
both computers and training to the point
where there is no way that the water can
be shut off in the Three Mile Island the
about half of the core melded and melted
through the bottom of the reactor vessel
the little one in the center but the
containment vessel contained all of it
all of the radionuclides and when they
finally went in most of the
radionuclides that were released were
plated out on the inside of the the
concrete shell and no nothing got out
there was a little bit got out
and that was when they decided that that
the zirconium had gotten hot enough to
react with the water and generate
hydrogen then they worried about a
hydrogen explosion and so they decided
that rather than having a hydrogen
explosion which could have maybe could
have don't know blown up the containment
vessel they vented the hydrogen and in
that hydrogen was a little bit of helium
which was radioactive
but the helium went out into the air
dispersed and the dose from that helium
was almost non-existent one millirem per
person in the Harrisburg area if someone
had left the Paris Berg to get away from
the dread radiation from TMI and they
moved to Denver they would have
increased their radiation exposure
Sevenfold from natural background you
got to remember again think talking
about Chernobyl that was really a
graphite fire it was lit by a reactor
core burning but the main reason for
there was a long dispersion of of stuff
including smoke and radio nuclides is
because the graphite was burning they
had a heck of a good charcoal I think
she had a roasted a cow over it you know
I'm being facetious here again but but
it was really a graphite a steam
explosion and in a graphite fire and I
just want to add one thing about them
and that question there was the and what
if terrorists or whatever an accident
would cause radiation for thousands of
years at Chernobyl 21 years later the
wildlife in the exclusion zone around
the well that was totally evacuated
except for some diehard Russian peasants
who were doing fine you know living
there and didn't want to move the
wildlife is flourishing probably because
humans aren't there to interfere with it
and the over since the Chernobyl area is
has low natural background radiation
it's a swamp with not many rocks so
if that's a hundred it's about a hundred
millirem a year naturally so now it's
gone up to something like 300 mil aroma
your average because of things hot there
are hot spots here and there but if the
people who were in the around living
around Chernobyl wanted to escape from
radiation and they moved to Finland they
would again be increasing their
radiation exposure so you have to think
when you say thousands of years well you
have to put it in some kind of context
some kind of perspective last question
and it's a common one basically the
economic question is it's whatever you
loving this is always bearing down on
it's what Ralph Cabana talked about when
he was in this room with Pierce ward
several months ago and a couple
questions here one from Peter boy or one
from Nick seasick I'll read into Nick's
version of it if nuclear is such a good
energy electricity source why are free
markets overwhelmingly choosing
cogeneration and microgeneration
over nuclear nuclear plants are only
being built with strong political and
economic support of centralized
governments like France well I can tell
you that when we visited Duke Energy and
looked at Oconee and McGuire nuclear
plants these are cash cows for the
utility and they because the start-up
costs for these reactors have been paid
off Oconee after eight years had paid
off its costs and electricity in the
southeast is cheap and has South
Carolina they haven't raised their rates
and something like 1986 Duke hasn't
raised it since 1991 or something so one
of the reasons utilities want more
nuclear reactors and they're applied I
think there was something like 34
applications maybe heading for the
Nuclear Regulatory Commission for to
build new reactors is because they are
profitable uranium is low in price
and if carbon if there's ever a carbon
tax nuclear which is already competitive
coal will de facto become cheaper than
coal so I don't I don't all fuel all
energy is subsidized and wind farms for
example in solar power I'm always
getting things from my utility trying to
get me to buy a windmill or a solar
installation or whatever these are very
I can't afford it actually I can't do
that's an expensive technology for you
know a writer to get behind I'm I'm
philosophically for these renewable
sources by the way I mean it's just that
in terms of money it's a deal breaker
and I think most people would rather not
climb up on the roof like my father used
to do and have to tinker with the solar
panels to get them to work so I I'm not
an economist and so on but I don't think
renewable energy is operating in a free
market either Denmark Germany it's
heavily subsidized Germany is basically
paying Germans to buy windmills or to
take on windmills and solar power
they're paying them so that's not to me
like free market but again I'm not an
economist so that's understand it the
sort of like hydroelectric dams which
are also carbon dioxide free there's
huge capital costs huge long process to
get it out there but once it's there
there's relatively quite low in fact
operating costs and nuclear seems to
have this quality that it's especially
these big ones thousand megawatt and
beer and they are getting bigger
presumably for economies of scale so
they're huge to build but I as my
understanding is that even though the
price of uranium fuel is going up once
they're built they're pretty cheap to
operate and you say they're a cash cow
well if that's the case why does the
nuclear industry who promises they're
not going to [ __ ] it up this time
you know just one more boom please God
are all over the government for you know
various subsidies in terms of insurance
of guarantee of loans of basically
trenches with money and will give you
power what's that about well the
price-anderson I knew the price-anderson
thing would come up so I brought with me
if I can find it I hope I remember to
bring it well I don't know if I did
after all but nuclear power is
self-insured this is often this is one
of those myths and there may be someone
in the audience who's more up to speed
on it but the price-anderson act is what
compels it set up the insurance plan for
nuclear plans insurance pools have paid
more than 200 million dollars in claims
and litigation costs since the Act went
into effect they dispersed approximately
71 million dollars about totalling
claims and litigation costs related to
1979 accident Three Mile Island to the
price-anderson Act provides no-fault
insurance to benefit the public in the
event of a nuclear power plant accident
the Nuclear Regulatory Commission deems
to be an extraordinary nuclear
occurrence in quotes the cost of this
insurance like all the costs of nuclear
generated electricity are borne by the
industry unlike the corresponding costs
of some other power sources risks from
hydro power mishaps dam failure and
resultant flooding for example are borne
directly by the public the 1977 failure
of the Teton dam in Idaho caused 500
million dollars in property damage but
the only compensation provided to those
affected was about 200 million dollars
in low cost government loans under the
price-anderson framework the public has
paid nothing the Act has proven so
successful that Congress has used it as
a model for legislation to protect the
public against potential losses or harm
from other hazards including faulty
vaccinations medical malpractice and
toxic waste also back to the economic
question which is sort of part of the
earthling external cost the European
Union has found nuclear powers external
costs regarding the environment and
public health care lower than those of
coal gas and solar power in terms of
avoidance costs to damage related to
ecosystems and global warming those of
nuclear power are on a par with
renewables sounds good thank you very
much
[Applause]